none of them want to look after her she  will literally perish this is why in  most of the world today still today  Virginia is so coveted and throughout  all of history it's been so coveted  because that's the only way to ensure  paternity she's a virgin I know that's  my baby she a virgin proves mine outside  of this modern science [ __ ] shaytan  the devil we have here in the West in  most of the world today without  virginity or at least a low body count  or at least uh anti-promiscuity you  can't tell that that's your baby so it's  a completely different thing you're  looking at the idea of a man a woman  being pregnant and coming to a group of  men and saying one of you has to take  care of me put up with me when I'm fat  and Moody and annoying and I need my  bills paid and all the men are gonna sit  there and go no [ __ ] no prove it's mine  you can't prove it bounce where it's  different if I get four women pregnant  we know who that we know the deal okay  so let me ask you